un grito de alegría y alivio Los
Seguidores de Juliana Sánchez celebraron
que la justicia británica negara su
extradición a Estados Unidos
la jueza Vanessa baritzer Consideró que
esa medida Sería opresiva para la
deteriorada salud mental de assange y
las condiciones de su detención en
Estados Unidos podrían empujarlo al
suicidio un fallo que la prometida a
sanch recibió con satisfacción y cautela
Victoria para Juliana Hoy es el primer
paso hacia la justicia en este caso
nos complace que el tribunal haya
reconocido la seriedad e inhumanidad de
lo que ha soportado y lo que
enfrentamientos
pero no olvidemos que la acusación de
Estados Unidos no ha sido abandonada
Aunque negó la extradición la jueza
rechazó los argumentos de la defensa de
assange que alegra el derecho a la
libertad de expresión para la
publicación de documentos filtrados hace
una década en los que se expusieron
irregularidades militares
estadounidenses en Irak y Afganistán por
eso el fallo resultó agridulce para
algunos
esto no fue una victoria para la
libertad de expresión por sus hallazgos
sobre la criminalización de la conducta
periodística y la aplicación de la ley
de secretos oficiales el gobierno
estadounidense apelará el fallo que
podría llegar en última instancia Hasta
el tribunal supremo de Reino Unido por
su parte la jueza decidirá el miércoles
sobre el pedido de más bajo fianza para
Samsung presentado por su defensa
mientras se resuelve el recurso de
Estados Unidos